hello my name is daniele podini
i am the department chair at george
washington university in the department
of forensic sciences
i'm also a forensic molecular biology
and today i will be talking to you
about some of the research that we've
been doing in my laboratory
the title of the talk is microhapa types
the next generation
forensic dna markers
so mixtures dna mixtures they represent
probably one of the greatest challenges
in forensic dna analysis
there's many reasons for that sample
degradation
can affect the the quality of the of the
mixture
allele sharing between contributors um
a little dropout and pcr artifacts
such as stutter and this is obviously
with the conventional
dna marker used in in
in our field which are short tandem
repeats
mastery parallel sequencing of sdrs or
short tandem repeats
can increase the ability
of the convoluted mixtures the
fact that we can sequence sdr and e
alleles can
enable the individualization of some
alleles that have the same size but
different sequences
it can also allow
to minimize fragment length so we can
increase the
the sensitivity of the assay when the
dna is degraded
and in some cases it can distinguish
between a stutter so an artifact of a
major contributor
in a mixture with an allele that
overlaps
convention normally would overlap with
with a
stutter of the major contribution of the
minor contributor and so
if we can distinguish those by by
sequence
that obviously is an advantage in
determining for example the number of
contributors
and determine the ratio between the
major and the minor
and obviously in the past couple of
years
we've seen uh probabilistic genotyping
and really help uh mixture the
convolution
uh via sdrs but when we talk about
massively parallel sequencing
this theoretical advantage that it would
offer
is is actually not not so
straightforward here we have an example
of
allele 22 of a locus one of the codis
loci d12
and the allele 20 the sequence of allele
22 has
in this particular case 13 agat
and then 8 agac and 1
ag 18. and if you look
in position of allele 21 and also from
allele 20
there's uh there's two stutter so a
minus
force excuse me a one is minus four
stutter
that is actually composed of of two
different sequences in fact
during the the creation of the stutter
so the the slippage of the polymerase
we have a loss uh sixty percent sixteen
percent of that stutter is a loss of one
repeat so it goes from 13 ag 80 to 12
but the ag ac remain eight whereas
six percent of the stutter uh or
six percent of the whole percentage is
um
a slippage at the ag ac so from one
single allele
allele 22 which is the original allele
of the individual
the actual dna contributor we have
two different stutters and then we have
the stutter of the stutter
and then we have the plus four stutter
so with a single
a single allele we're actually
generating another five artifacts
so if you can imagine that if there's a
minor contributor there
whose dna is at the level of the stutter
it gets really difficult to interpret
which a leo
is an actual artifact versus one
being a stutter obviously if it's in
stutter position
so although
mastery para secret has the potential to
increase the capability of the
convoluting mixtures
it still has a lot of challenges and and
to model
these different types of artifacts in
probabilistic genotyping
it's very complex it's not something
that's really straightforward
and this is where micro hypertypes come
in microhapa types are
novel forensic dna marker
that was initially thought by professor
ken
kidd from yale university and
what they are are a set of snips within
a fragment that can be amplified so
approximately you know 300 nucleotides
or less and
the smaller these fragments the greater
their sensitivity in
in degraded dna and in this fragment
that can be amplified we have multiple
snips
and the pattern of these things so the
association between the step alleles
creates different haplotypes so normally
with the senger sequencing which is the
kind of the old sequencing method that's
been used for
several years the entire human genome
project was based with
sanger was based on sanger sequencing
you see right there you see a gc
sorry a cg a cg and then to a
g's and we don't know based on on sanger
sequencing if that first
c is associated to the second c or
whether
it's associated to the g meaning on
which chromosome they are
but with massively parallel sequencing
we can actually separate the two
chromosome because we clonally sequence
each individual chromosome
and so in this case we're able to see
that one haplotype
so for example the one that's inherited
by the father we have a c
c h a and whereas the other chromosome
is ggg
and so those two are essentially those
two haplotypes are essentially
two alleles but you can have multiple
combinations
okay so that's what a micro haplotype is
and the advantages of using micro
haplotypes are several
they first of all there's no
stutter because there's there's not a
sequence that's repeated multiple times
as the polymerase
amplifies that region there's no
slippage and obviously they can be
selected appropriately so
so the the efficiency of the
amplification
is high they are snips
so uh they're based on snips so the
mutation rate is a lot lower than
short tandem repeats and so they they
can be very useful
in relationship testing
they um can be useful because of
the stutter and because there's this uh
[Music]
because there's a stutter in an
imbalanced mixture
you and you would not have the issue
that you have with strs where
stutters can overlap with alleles of the
minor contributor that that issue is
absent
modeling in probabilistic genotyping
is much easier because you don't have
the stutter issue at all
and also all the alleles within the same
locus have the same size with sdrs
you may have alleles that are much
larger than others
because they may have a lot more teeth
and so this gives a
the larger allele an amplification
disadvantage
if there's inhibition or if the dna is
degraded so
you don't have that issue so
there are several advantages there are
some disadvantages of course
for example they are less polymorphic
than sdrs
so you need to increase the number of
law style that you amplify that you
co-amplify
in multiplex to get the same power of
discrimination that you have with sdrs
so designing a multiplex assay may be
more complex
and obviously although i don't have it
on the slide they're based on massively
parallel sequencing which is
more expensive at least right now and
going forward i think
massively parallel sequencing will
improve throughput will increase there
will be
a better way to increase the number of
samples that you cannot
analyze at the same time and so there's
you know it's very promising
so in as i said earlier
professor kidd is the one that thought
of this and he started publishing paper
the first paper was as i showed here in
2013 and there were
and he was the one that mostly published
for for the first five years on this but
then there was an explosion of
of papers and there's actually
more that are that have come out and are
are coming out
uh including a couple that we submitted
and we're waiting for
the reviewers to get back to us
and so the community has really
um there's consensus
in the community that this is actually a
good forensic dna market
so we received funding from nij to
develop an assay based on a panel that
was identified by dr
kidd in collaboration with others
including our group
we selected a subset of this panel based
on two parameters one
is e or effective number of alleles
and the other parameter was uh is
informativeness so the effective number
of audio
is essentially um how it tells us
how discriminating is this particular
locus
so essentially the the
distribution of the alleles that this
particular locus has
and and how
balanced this the allele frequency of
the ldls that are identified for the
strokes
the informativeness instead tells us how
unique are certain alleles to certain
populations so
in essence ae allows us to discriminate
individuals
within the same population or across
population within whereas the
informativeness a higher information
gives us
the ability to discriminate between
individuals from different populations
so we selected a panel based on that and
we
analyzed multiple samples the throughput
uh the process of the analysis was
uh first the library prep preparation we
we did both manual and using students as
part of their projects
and also automated library prep
then we did what's called chip
templating well the templating and
loading on the chip so
so the libraries get go through a
process of a motion pcr
and then eventually they get purified
and loaded onto the chip
and then they were sequenced on the ion
s5 so this is the
ion s5 mps platform
then we worked on
pipelines for bioinformatic pipelines to
process the data
using some that were provided by thermal
fissures
other others that we developed and the
final output
in this particular case kind of mimics
what the
conventional sdr analysis looks like so
we have a in this case we have a bar as
opposed to having a peak
and the height of the bar represents how
many
individual reads of that particular
sequence
have been found and at the bottom you
see a g
and gg are the two alleles meaning a and
one on one chromosome we have at the
first snip and a at the second
sniper g in the other chromosome we have
two
g's and these are not necessarily
contiguous they can be separated as i
showed you in the previous slide
and we did several studies so i'm going
to go through some of them here
i don't have time to go through all of
them but
if anybody's interested they can contact
me
so we did a mixture study oh the
first is the sensitivity so the
sensitivity that we we were able to
obtain we obtained full profiles down to
50 picograms of input dna
which is very similar if not better than
most of the conventional sdr kits that
are commercially used by prime labs
right now
so we developed multiple mixtures
starting from 10 to 1 to
twenty to one forty to one even down to
eighty to one
and and then we did multiple
contributors and and
this slide kind of shows you the
distribution of types of mixtures that
we looked at
we obtained the full profiles for most
of them obviously as we
increase the ratio between the major and
the minor we're we're
inputting always less amount of dna of
the minor given that
the overall amount of dna is as you can
see on the right of the slide
is one nanogram so as you increase the
ratio between the two
you're always putting in less and less
of the minor contributor so we started
seeing some
as expected some a little dropout and
the 20 to one
a lot of a allele dropout and 40 to 1
and the complete drop out of the minor
contributor in there in the 80 to 1
which was expected
we analyzed those mixtures in multiple
ways so we used our
micro haplotype assay we also used
the conventional global filer kit with
the capillary electrophoresis
the 24 loci assay that is
validated in many laboratories and then
we use the
the new precision id global filer engine
s
ngs sdr panel version two and that is
that includes all the 24 law side that
are in the
conventional ce global filer plus
an additional set of lost eye that
increase the
power discrimination of the assay so we
analyze the same mixture with the same
amount of dna
in these three different ways and here
are the data
so this is an example we're talking
about sensitivity
20 to a 20 to 1 ratio as we expect we
see some dropout of the minor
contributor
with conventional c so for example
at locus d3 we see the 16 and the 18 of
the minor contributor that are very low
uh wwa we see the 18
then we see some drop out and some are
masked so for example at local css
1po the minor contributor is number 12
which is obviously masked
in this case by the major who is 912.
the to 421 ratio as as we expect that we
don't see
any of the minor contributor with this
conventional ce
when looking at the same
samples but tested with massively
parallel
sequencing global filer kit
we end up getting a little bit more
information of the minor contributor
and again this the the just navigates
you through this plot
the height of the bar represent the
individual sequences
and the number underneath each bar
represents the allele call
and that so these are sequenced meaning
the software
reads the the sequence uh
that's that's generated by the secrecy
on the chip
and then it counts the individual
repeats and then it
develops this at this output so it's
it's um
kind of an our artificial really
artificial output as opposed to
the peaks that we were seeing in the
previous slide
which are you know the height of the
peak is actually a consequence of the
amount of fluorescence that is generated
by the pcr product as it goes through
the capillary
and so almost complete dropout
well so at the 20 to 1 ratio we see a
lot of the minor contributor more than
we were seeing with
ce in the 40 to 1 ratio essentially we
see
complete dropout we see a few elevated
stutters like
in d4 s 2408
we see a little bit of the 10 that
is slightly above the stutter threshold
but this is
cannot be considered reliable because
we haven't this is a new kit we hadn't
done a thorough
actual internal validation so we don't
have stellar threshold we're just using
the ones that are
produ that were given by default and
again there's there's not been enough
processing of this kit to be able to
determine whether that 10 is actually
above the stutter threshold meaning
there's the minor contributors
that's increasing the the read count
uh okay now the same mixtures
with uh micro haplotypes we
see a significant amount of alleles of
the minor contributor
at the 20 to 1 ratio where
at the 40 to 1 ratio obviously we have
more dropout but we're still
detecting a good amount of alleles of
the miner
54 to be to be specific and
22 alleles of the minor contributor and
we'll see later i have a slide
showing that the random match
probability that is generated
with just these 22 alleles of the minor
contributor
is sufficient is strong is pretty
powerful we're getting you know
uh one in a million or around that area
so
so we're going from a stick uh sorry
um a profile that's analyzed with ce
that yields nothing 40 to one we didn't
get anything to
something that can give us a random
match probability of one in a minute so
it's a very
powerful technique now
the idea here okay we've seen that it
actually has the the potential of
i'm not going to say replace sdrs
because sdrs are here to stay
there's an enormous enormous inertia of
you know the convicted offender database
that has
you know millions and millions of
profiles
sdr profiles there's forensic profiles
within codis that are obviously useful
potentially useful to identify offenders
that haven't been
officially typed yet so sdrs are here to
stay but it has the potential
to enhance mixed reconvolution or to
complement sdrs
but in order for this to happen we have
to make them attractive to
forensic scientists so so how can we
make them attractive so
um first of all there has to be
user-friendly software
and that makes it easier uh
to to look at this sample and it has to
be robust
developing a bioinformatic pipeline is
not
as easy as i thought at least when i got
into this field
and you know converting um
so the out the conventional output is
pretty straightforward from ce so the
the amount of fluorescent
generates a signal that's detected and
kind of plotted into
you know that graphical representation
then they were so used to
the bioinformatics there's a lot of
noise there's so many more samples it's
something that cannot be done manually
so it's a lot more complex complex
then we need allele frequency because if
we
frequencies are what allows us to
determine the frequency of a profile so
we have a match between the evidence and
a suspect
but we can't just say it's a match we
have to provide
a statistical significance of this match
or call it random match probability
we call it likelihood ratio it depends
and then they have to be amenable
to probabilistic genotyping it's
the software is complex enough the the
number of loss high are
much greater than than with sdrs because
you want to you want to obtain a as i
said earlier you need more low side
to obtain the same discrimination power
so you can't really do it manually and
as
we've seen in the community everybody's
shifting to probably
genotyping because it makes things so
much
more consistent much more
straightforward our
challenges to it but this is something
that
would be a must for micro habitats to be
implemented
and finally there has to be an
international consensus on the
on the final panel that we want to use
as a community and that is really
crucial and i'm not going to talk about
it now
because
i really haven't been working on this
right now
directly but it's something that's
extremely important because
that is what's going to allow the
companies that the manufacturers of this
kit these molecular biology kits who to
then
decide whether it's worth investing
their resources in developing a panel so
there has to be consensus between the
community on
which are the law sites to type so
user-friendly software
so we here is an example of
a kind of an alpha version of a plugin
for armed expert and this is um
thanks to brian young you see his
picture at the bottom of the left
and obviously this doesn't doesn't tell
you much i have i zoomed into one of
them so here
is just a
plot plotting of the results of a set of
microhaps of our panel again the height
of the bar
represents the coverage meaning how many
sequences have been identified with that
particular pattern
the label on the top shows you the
allele call and right now they've been
labeled with
with a particular code but that can be
adapted to
anything we want the locus name is at
the top
and the the two alleles are what you see
at the bottom so the bar represents the
the individual allele so so as you can
see now this the saw there's some
imbalance this is a single star sample
so ideally
you would want you know one peak when
the individuals homozygote are two
balanced
bars i should say when the
alleles when there's when the
individual's heterozygote
but we see like in the center where
uh it says unique identification code
right in the center you see that there's
two alleles for that locus and they're
significantly imbalanced there's
almost twice the amount of one versus
the other so
that's a a biopharmatic issue so
we have to optimize the the pipeline
in order to clean better and to identify
which ones are
the actual alleles and and you see a
couple of those
also also we want to try and and and
that's more kind of a
pcr primer concentration issue try to
balance the
the all the different low sides so
so that the coverage is similar across
the low side
but this is an example of how we would
want a software so you
kind of select the sample you run the
software and you get these bars and then
obviously the output is that they have
to be exported into a table that can be
used for
uh comparison and if it's a mixture
there could be some
manual interpretation initial manual
into partition but this is a good way to
visualize
the sample and it's attractive to
old-school
dna analysts that are used to looking at
at peaks
right then the bioinformatician doesn't
really look at this anymore
so this is really for for us molecular
biologists or
dna analysts in terms of allele
frequencies
we've uh generated
we've sequenced the several samples for
for the purpose of generating allele
frequencies for the
major u.s population so african american
european americans
east asian american southwest hispanics
and we've
typed also um over 800 samples
14 different populations throughout the
world so we we have
the allele frequencies that that can be
used already
on on the set that we've on the 74
uh effects that we've analyzed and we've
also
tested how well we could use
microhappiness
to predict the ancestry of an individual
so
for that we use the allele frequencies
that were generated
for many more populations across the
world by dr ken
kidd and and his lab and here's an
example of how ancestry prediction could
be done
so here these are individuals of african
descent
and what you see uh what you see
is so the plot represents the frequency
of each individual
profile in all the populations that are
listed on the top of that
graph so and these are 20 individuals of
african american descent so that's the
biogeographic ancestry
and as you can see the frequency of
their profile is
higher in operations from africa
so as you move from from left to right
at a certain point there's a drop which
corresponds to individual
allele frequencies that were from
individuals of european descent
and although on the graph there's not
much
difference but each one of those lines
those
horizontal lines is three orders of
magnitude so
so in essence uh the the
as you drop what is it one two three or
four lines it's like 12 orders of
magnitude
difference in terms of the frequency of
that profile in that population
so you clearly see a pattern of
individuals from
of african-american effect these are
europeans and again you see that their
frequency
bumps up when we're using the frequency
the overall frequency of the profile
comes up when you're
when we're looking at uh when we're
using allele frequencies from
european individuals these are
east asians um
and these are selfless hispanic
individuals and as
south of hispanics are actually an admix
between
europeans and native americans
and you see that the frequency
goes up in both which is what we would
expect
here's an example of those are kind of
the averages
that i approach that i showed you before
and you see also and
this is a single individual in purple
that was a
profile from a native american
individual and you see that the
frequency
is relatively low across africa in
europe it goes out
up a bit in east asia and then it goes
up again
significantly up obviously in when we
use the new frequencies from individuals
of native american the state so this
shows you that
they actually have the potential to
provide some some ancestry information
and here's kind of a different approach
so we're using a multivariate
statistical approach that
that uses a logistic regression
and pca combined and
these are some of our samples and as you
can see the the plot the individuals are
are well separated into different parts
of the plot
so this is another approach so you would
add an unknown individual
the software would plot it in in one of
these positions and so you could use
this as a as a method to predict the
answers you know we're still working on
this part
but it definitely has potential and this
is in collaboration with
the cabinetry group of rome
and the university la sapienza who've
been
using this statistical approach on str's
and showing some really promising data
and so because microhaps
carry more ancestry information than
sdrs
it is like it these are preliminary data
we're seeing that
that it has the potential to really help
in this
process
this is a kind of an example of
combining
uh mixture interpretation and ancestry
prediction so
on on the left we have the likelihood
ratio of the
the observing uh this particular profile
[Music]
if it's an individual of european
american descent
versus in blue a european uh
an individual uh african american
descent
meaning that's it's 10 times the 16
times more likely to observe this
particular profile if it's a
european if the dna came from a european
versus an african-american whereas
the red bar shows shows us that it's
about
approximately a thousand times more
likely to observe this
profile if it's an individual of
european descent than if an
individual from hispanic is that and um
again european versus asian is a lot
higher so
and this is for the alleles of the minor
contributor
in the 20 to one this is to the left and
to the right
it is for the 40 to 1. on the right side
you see the random match probability so
you see that the random match
probability
uh for the profile
is in the and that is kind of the
average
is in you know the 10 to the 19. so
we're talking
trillions of trillions so it's a very
very high number
um and this is for the minor contributor
of the 20 to one
the minor contributor of the 40 to 1
that profile is around
one in a million so it's still uh pretty
strong
although the ancestry information that
we're getting out of the 421
is is not as informative the conclusion
here is that we could say that the
the minor contributor of the 21 mixture
is
um most likely of individual
of european descent possibly hispanic
descent but
we can probably exclude
or assume extremely unlikely that the
individual is
of african-american descent or
east asian american
probably genotyping and this is the
research that we're currently working
on so taking the data
that the output data from
our bioinformatic pipelines and then
throwing it into probabilistic
genotyping to see if it works and for
this
we've been working on using lr mix
studio which is a semi-continuous model
that basically doesn't look at the
height of the peak so the amount of dna
but simply looks at the presence or
absence of alleles
and then we in collaboration with dr
charles brenner we've been
um using dna view mixture solution who
that was adapted by dr brenner to in
import
inputting or importing
microhap data and i don't have many
examples here
in the interest of time but we've
demonstrated that actually works pretty
well
and microhaps are are a good
a good tool that can be easily adapted
to producing genotyping
because of its characteristics that i
mentioned earlier you don't have to
model stutter
fragment you don't have to model size
between alleles of the same locus as you
have to do with
sdrs and so it's actually working pretty
well and this is an example
of a five percent mixture
where the hypothesis uh are
that um either it's a mixture between
two individual b and c plus three
unknowns or
uh four uh sorry a mixture of five
individuals b and c
but plus three unknowns or b plus plus
four unknowns
so in this essentially the person of
interest as
mr c in this case which is in this
particular case
was the in intermediate contributors to
the one that's applied
and so a mixture solution is able to
very effectively deconvolute the mixture
and attribute the alleles to
the different individuals particularly
the intermediate person
and it gives us uh you know one
times 10 to the 78 likelihood ratio
which i don't know even how to say it in
terms of of
um you know trillions of quadrillions or
whatever it is
whereas um alarmic studio it gives us
um you know eight times ten to three so
you would say it's
eight eight thousand times more likely
to observe this mixture
if it's a mixture between bc and three
unknowns that fits the mixture between
b and four unknowns and we we expect
that lr mix studio doesn't have the same
power
of of the convolution because it's not
using peak height or
in this case coverage so
this kind of demonstrates that these are
[Music]
microwaves are a good marker for for
probabilistic genotype
now we wanted to take it a step further
so we we've been focusing
on the snips that define the microhap so
the ones that initially dr
kidd identified these are this is an
example of an amplicon and those
red bars represent the location of the
individual snips
so these are the ones that define the
local so the
profile you know aaa gg or you know a at
the first red bar
a at the second red bar g and g at the
third and fourth red bars okay but but
there's a lot of real estate there a lot
of
sequences that we've initially been
ignoring so our initial pipeline was
actually only focusing on the four snips
but there's a yeah there's a lot of
potential uh
genetic variation that can occur there
and the the greater the number of low
side that we're analyzing so the greater
the number of
this this genetic real estate that we're
looking at
the greater are the chances that an
individual has a rare snip
that is identified so here is an example
these are the two uh microhaps that
define
the sorry the two snips that define the
microhop
but then if you look at the
all those potential snips that have been
identified
they can there can be variation there
and some of it may be not informative
because maybe it's completely linked
with the allele that we are already
genotyping
but others may not be and
here's an example of an individual that
is
homozygote ga based on
uh focusing on the two snips that define
the microhap
but when we actually go and sequence the
individual we see that there's another
snip variation right there that is
extremely rare
as you can see it's been identified very
rarely
in individuals of african descent
but in uh it's been
virtually not seen in all the other
populations so so this
this individual now becomes heterozygote
so we goes from homozygote to
heterozygote not only that but it
increases the power of discrimination
this profile
incredibly so in a mixture for example
we would be able to again
discriminate but by adding this rare
allele
which would be gga we increase
the the power of discrimination
and the chances of also identifying the
number of contributors to a mixture
the next frontier of these microhaps
is already being kind of
addressed by by dr kidd who is now
focused on identifying
microhaps that are very small and the
advantage of these small microhaps is
that they're going to be a lot more
effective
on extremely degraded dna so
sdrs go from approximately 100
onward and with massively parallel
sequencing maybe you can stay within you
know between 100 and
200 250 something like that so
um
dna is not that big fragments
but but if the dna is significantly
degraded you're not going to get a good
profile
if you focus on fragments that are
smaller than 50 base pairs
you can you can actually uh increase the
discrimination power
and so here are um here's a
structure plot of 108
microhaps that are smaller than 50 base
pairs and as you can see
they have they have a very good
informativeness
and although it's not shown in the slide
they also have a good
ae so they have a great potential
for typing degraded dna
where sdrs would fail
so here are the various things that
we're still working on
improving our mixture the convolutional
estrogen prediction
degraded dna looking at relationship
testing
how effective they are and not only you
know father
child but siblings step siblings
cousins and so forth and we're
in the process of publishing the
allele frequencies and the mixture
studies and also
optimizing the bioinformatic pipeline
which is not a small
undertaking with that i also
want to thank all the people that worked
to date that you've seen there's all my
gw students
particularly fabio ordoni
who is the one on the
right of the picture on the bottom right
you see me ken kidd and
fabio who's done a lot of work here and
also all the the students of the program
in this picture there's nina
sharia drew myself and fabio again so
they've they've all
helped a lot and other students that i
wanted there's too many to mention
but also and especially nij for funding
the research that we've been
working on that will help their help the
help of thermo fisher
niche vision uh
we wouldn't have been able to generate
this data
for that thank you so much